هل يتوقع الامريكيون تصدع النظام الروسي
الحالي في اعقاب ما يصفه بعضهم بالمحاوله
الانقلابيه الفاشله لزعيم مجموعه فاجنر
حتى اللحظه يؤكد البيت الابيض انه مازال
مبكرا معرفه تداعيات ما حدث
يراقب عن كثب الاوضاع في روسيا تحديدا
فيما يتعلق بالاستقرار الاستراتيجي نظرا
لامتلاك روسيا هذا الجيش الضخم ولكن
تحديدا القوه النوويه نتحدث عن دوله كبيره
جدا روسيا هي اكبر دوله في العالم حياه
المساحه دوله لديها على الاقل حدود مع 14
دوله اخرى لديها على الاقل حدود 2500 كلم
مع دول البلطيق الدوله لديها على الاقل
5900 راس ناوي هل اتخذت المؤسسه العسكريه
الامريكيه او وزاره الدفاع تحديدا اي
اجراءات او قامت باي تعديلات في
استراتيجيتها ازاء روسيا الانقسام
ضعفا بنظر البيت الابيض لدى الرئيس بوتين
كون ان بعضن كانت احدى اهم ادوات حربه في
اوكرانيا
على السلطه في روسيا الى اضعاف بوتين خاصه
صوره باعتبارات قوي المسؤوله الرفيع فيها
قال لي بان الولايات المتحده لطالما
اعتبرت فاجنر منظمه اجراميه عابره للقارات
مزعزعه للاستقرار تخلف الخراب حيثما حلت
وتقوم على استغلال الموارد وبالتالي دورها
تحديدا في افريقيا هو دور تدميريك الاداره
الامريكيه اصدرت اوامر بارسال المزيد من
المعدات العسكريه حوالي نصف مليار قيمه
المعدات العسكريه هذه رابع حزمه خلال اقل
من عشره ايام ترسل الى اوكرانيا قلت
للرئيس فلودي ميرسي انه بصرف النظر عم ا
سيحصل في روسيا فاننا نحن الامريكيين سنظل
ندعم دفاعات اوكرانيا وسيادتها ووحده
اراضيها
لم تعد فاغنر موجوده على الجبهه الاماميه
للمعركه قبل سته عشر شهرا كانت القوات
الروسيه على اعتاب مدينه كييف معتقده انها
ستسيطر على المدينه في غضون ايام وتمحو
اوكرانيا من الخريطه اما الان كان عليها
التركيز على موسكو ضد المرتزقه هذا يثير
الكثير من الاسئله العميقه هناك سيناريو
يقول بوتين سيتم اضعافه نظامه تصدع هناك
سيناريو اخر يقول سيخرج من هذه الازمه
وقبضته على الحكم معززه ماذا يعني كلا
السيناريوهين للولايات المتحده
اعتبر مؤشر جيد على ما يتعلق فيما يتعلق
بالحرب الاوكرانيه هناك حاله ضعف بشكل او
اخر اهتزاد للصوره داخليه لبوتين يذكرني
بما حدث في حالات اخرى تاريخيه عبد الرحيم
مثلا
حاله هتلر في المانيا انهزم عندما حاول
[موسيقى]
العالميه كبلد ولولا يقظه السلطات الماليه
لكن اليوم بلدا منبوذا ذلك بفضل تعاوننا
مع الروس يعني صحيفه
نشرت مقاله تحت عنوان بوتين يتحرك للتحكم
في امبراطوريه فاجنا نائب وزير الخارجيه
الروسي طار الى دمشق ليبلغ الرئيس بشار
الاسد لان قوات فاجنر لن تعمل هناك
باستقلاليه بعد الان
مسؤولون كبار في الخارجي الروسيه هاتفه
رئيس جمهوريه افريقيا الوسطى لتقديم
تطمينات بان ازمه يوم السبت الماضي لن
تقود التوسع الروسي في افريقيا
طائرات حكوميه روسيه حلقت من سوريا الى
مالي محطه رئيسيه اخرى من محطات فاجنر
الرئيسه في الخارج هناك حضور قوي جدا في
هذه البلدان وهذا الحضور ياخذ اشكال
مختلفه جزء منه متعلق بمهامات قتاليه
الحاجه التانيه فيما يتعلق بتقديم خدمات
امنيه لبعض المؤسسات الموجوده في هذه
الدول الافريقيه الامر الثالث القيام به
حملات اعلاميه مضلله لصالح الانظمه
السلطويه الموجوده في افريقيا كيف ينظر
الامري
كيون ومنافستها على النفوذ في السودان
ومالي ومناطق اخرى في افريقيا والولايات
المتحده على هي المجموعه اجراميه دوليه
وقد فرضت عقوبات على عدد من شركات الوهميه
التابعه للرغمه في افريقيا وخاصه الاتحاد
الاخرى والتعامل في عمليات
تنقيب المناجم مع الذهبي ولا الماس والخوف
الرئيسي لواشنط من هو المتعلق بقيامها
باستخراج المعادن الرئيسيه الموجوده طبعا
غنيه تعتبر الدوله الثالثه في افريقيا في
انتاج الذهب لديها على الاقل لكم حادثه
تين يعني مليون طن ذهب
لكي يدربوا العسكريين الماليين على
استخدام السلاح الروسي واذا فهم بعض
الشركات لذلك بطريقه مختلفه واعطوه علامه
فان ذلك ليس مشكلتنا نحن الماليين
ليس فقط انها تعارض وتوق بعض المجموعات
الجهاديه في مالي وهذا يمكن نقول انه امر
جيد ولكنه ايضا تقوم
بابقاء على حكومه غير ديمقراطيه في السلطه
تمثل عقبه الامريكيه فيما يتعلق بدعمها
المتواصل اولا دعم المالي لموسكو نشر نفوذ
الروسي في القرن الافريقيه
تداعيات المرتبطه بمجموعه في افريقيا
فاننا سنواصل مراقبه الوضع وسبق ان قلنا
ان تاثير المجموعه مزعزع للاستقرار في تلك
المنطقه ولا شك انها تمثل تهديده
في استخراج الذهب مناجم في جنوب السودان
وايضا قدمت بعض الدعم لقوات الدعم السريع
وجود القتال بين قوات الحكوميه وفي
السودان وقوات الدعم السريع هذا بالتاكيد
امر معقد جدا فهدف روسيا هناك ولديها
قاعده في بورت سوزان خوف الرئيس الامريكا
متعلق
بالنفوز الروسي ثم نفوذ الصيني فيما يتعلق
هذه المنطقه هناك حاجه امريكيه لدفع هذا
النفوس الى الخلف وبالتالي هي تحاول تدعم
شكلها اخر وجود انظمه قويه بعد انظمه
الديمقراطيه الى اي مدى تعتقد انت انما
حصل
قد عزز للاداره الامريكيه الخيط الرابط
بين افريقيا والشرق الاوسط واوكرانيا
هناك
بالتاكيد رابط فعلا
وهناك ايضا جهد لعزل وفصل دوره في روسيا
وهذا يعني
النشاط في اوكرانيا ودوره فاغنا في
افريقيا من جانب ربما في سوريا من جانب
اخر اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده تشعر بقلق
شديد حول الدوله تقوم به مجموعه فيتنار في
كل من روسيا حيث شارك بشكل رئيسي في
اوكرانيا وايضا نشاطاتها في افريقيا وايضا
سوريا